but like yeah even like you know I I get
it with like in America for example like
there is definitely more of a diversity
in terms of like the surface level with
the people like you know and not even
talking about like an accent wise right
like you know obviously the moment
someone opens their mouth for the most
part you know roughly whereabouts
they're from all right but like I still
feel like yeah it's kind of said like
they're still at the end of the day
regardless of if I was in Mississippi or
Seattle I'm like it's still it's
American they're still Americans and and
maybe it's because yeah maybe it's
because there's this like what do you
think that thing is then I don't know I
think it says um you know I realize I'm
doing this tour and speaking to way more
Americans than I ever have in my life is
that Americans are like super [ __ ]
nice and they're really hospitable
hospitable for sure yeah they're always
really nice and then occasionally they
might just say something or something
gets brought up and then you know like
if for some reason politics is ever
mentioned they say something like oh
oh okay yeah well we disagree on this
yeah well I keep my mouth shut I never
bring it up but I notice some people
like you cannot like okay between like
super left people and super right people
initially on the like if you're just
talking you cannot tell the difference
between it's just like which something
gets said oh my God does it come out
very fast there's like a rhythm to the
conversation that I think is very
uniquely American and I don't know
exactly how I can describe it yeah I
don't know if it's because I'm not
American yeah I can't see it but
everyone feels super nice super
welcoming and then if if for some reason
something's ever brought up that is
political even remotely so it flips to
the American that you see on the TV
right you know what I mean where you
have these these very strong opinionated
people who are very open and then you're
like ah okay this is the America you see
on the TV which is why in a way it kind
of made me appreciate America more in
the sense that I don't think it's all
doom and gloom where because I'm on TV
bro
they make America look god-awful yeah
they are doing you dirty and America
doesn't themself because they know
that's the that's what gets clicks yeah
of course um and so on on TV and from
movies and all the stuff you get the
impression that Americans are [ __ ]
insane and just to some extent in
Florida they are yeah yeah it is the
case but like I think most people in
America are super chill super nice
really awesome to talk to just don't
bring up politics yeah ever it's it's
funny because we actually funnily enough
we went you know everyone's just like oh
how many like how many more things you
have to [ __ ] on about America and we we
found a lot don't worry about that but
we also found things we liked about
America as well yeah because I I just
liked how you always knew where you
stood with an American you know because
I grew up in I grew up in British
culture where everything's behind like
10 layers of [ __ ] sarcasm or
something like that is someone being
passive aggressive or not you have to go
through like 10 lays to figure it out
like I get sent an email right a
business email he didn't he used regards
instead of kind regards is is he like am
I on it like a [ __ ] he's an [ __ ] did
I do something wrong to piss him off or
did he forget I don't know with an
American you always know where you stand
you know because they'll they email will
start with dear [ __ ]
corrects there they just tell you
exactly how they're feeling you don't
have to like hide behind like so much
bullshittery conversation is always nice
I always had a great time you know as
much as I hate tipping uh it was great
for getting rid of change that I didn't
want oh yeah just round out I'm like
this is awesome hold up wait this is a
scam yeah tipping was a joke at times oh
yeah so it is somewhat convenient I
understand why some Americans are so
attached to it but also never ever let
that [ __ ] leave America please get that
out of my country yeah
um uh and there's some other stuff that
was nice just people were always
Pleasant yeah
um but that was the thing right it's
like I don't know when it comes to like
the hospital boldness of like the
average American like for sure like I
think we all discovered it's like yeah
Americans for the most part very
welcoming you know when when they mean
to be welcoming and they're very
hospitable and they want to make sure
that you're having the best time that
you can in their country yeah right but
then at the same time I'm just like
is that the average American or is that
just the average trash taste fan yeah
you know that was a part of me where I'm
just like we spoke to a lot of people
outside of the trash days fans obviously
because we had a lot of days where we
were just not doing shows yeah and also
we were just talking to people normally
it was always a good time I know
definitely I don't think I had any bad
experiences
um but I'm white though so I don't know
if that place
yeah I had a like I've got a bit of an
experience in Detroit Yeah
well yeah people who missed out on that
story yeah I mean I I was like wait so
we go to the tour you had a show in
Detroit and you know I've heard I had
heard about Detroit's reputation and
everything like that before
yes uh so I came out like Garnet so uh
there was this like anime shop there was
like one block away so I was like what's
the worst thing that could happen if I
just go to this in Detroit to go to an
anime shop no no no there was just one
that was just like a block away from our
well like uh from the venue from the
venue and I was like there's nothing we
got like three hours to kill yeah
um I was like well why not check it out
why not check out the anime shop just to
see what the the Detroit scene is like
right we walk out and I'm with my uh
with uh our producer at the time and I'm
walking around it's actually like a
really bougie area we had like really
nice coffee shops really nice Detroit
wasn't as bad yeah from what I'd heard
from Detroit sound like yeah like the
area room was quite nice yeah it was
nice the streets were clean and I was
like damn this is not the image of
Detroit that I thought it was gonna be
obviously I know there are some areas
that are obviously of course but it was
it was it was like a nice bougie area
and I remember talk like turning to my
producer be like wow Detroit's not what
I thought he was going to be at it at
all this is like a really nice looking
area this is really bougie
um as soon as I finish the sentence I
walk around the corner and then there's
this guy walking up towards us he sees
me and he goes you don't belong here get
out
and I was just like uh uh is he talking
to me I just I don't know if he's
talking to me maybe it's just a crazy
guy let's just go into the store so we
quickly like Shuffle into like the store
and as I opened the door I just here in
the corner of my ear I'm talking to you
boy get out now and I'm like I'm just
I'm just [ __ ] I'm just gonna go in
and just uh find solace in the [ __ ]
anime store that would have been so
scary yeah [ __ ] yeah
um and then I was like okay there's this
there's
there it is okay there it is not good
but that was the only time anything ever
happened right to any of us yeah I think
so I mean I got I I definitely if
there's one thing I learned on this tour
is how to talk to homeless people and
get out of those situations because
there were many times throughout the
tour where you know after the show you
know we were just kind of like be
hanging outside of the bus you know just
like talking and chatting getting some
fresh air stuff like that and then you
know usually it's at like midnight or
like one in the morning yeah and you
know because we're for the most part
parked in front of a venue it's like you
know right on the side stream right yeah
and of course you know with uh most
American towns there's a lot of homeless
people you know walking around at night
yeah and oh my God I probably maybe con
it was in contact with like I want to
say like 50 all together on this tour
homeless people every single tour there
was at least one or two homelessness who
walk up to us and I used I used the diet
I was gonna say I I understand why diet
is has this technique now the first one
in in Minnesota dude walks up you know
asking for change or whatever it was I
don't know he was like slurring his
words and I just I hit him with the
sorry sorry man yeah anyway he just like
grumbled and was just like oh at least
you're nice about it
and I was like oh my God
my God yeah because I feel like okay in
terms of like american-ness right there
is like an inbred skill in like every
Americanization
we drove through Alabama once and it
just changed me man it changed like
every American has this like ingrained
skill yeah to
um to de-escalate with homeless people
yes I'm I and I saw it like I remember
we were outside like the Texas venue and
like this this homeless guy comes up and
it's me you and Aaron uh and I remember
do you remember the homeless guy that
was like yo Jesus there was Jay-Z
performing here and and and and like
Aaron was like a full-on conversation
with him and I'm thinking like he asked
like he asked us like for crack and
stuff like yeah and I was just like I I
I don't know what I'm doing I'm not
going to say [ __ ] can't now which is
completely silent yeah we were just
completely slow and Aaron just like
dealt with it like a [ __ ] bro he was
just like nah sorry bro yeah sorry yeah
I mean I think a lot of the times they
get homes people get demonized too much
right at the end of the day they're the
[ __ ] people who you know for whatever
reason would like didn't life didn't go
their way yeah I think you know just
showing a bit of compassion they
appreciate that oh no of course like if
there's if there's one thing I've
learned it's like the the worst I guess
reaction you can get from a homeless
person is ignoring them yeah you know
because if you ignore them then that's
when they get pissed off right because
if you deal with it just like calmly and
just you know candidly just being sorry
man you're a human right no human wants
to feel ignored sorry man have a good
night just stuff like that they're good
yeah but like I I notice it's just like
very different in America versus like
the rest of the world for example
because oh yeah in most places in the
world you do ignore you know that's
that's kind of like that's kind of like
what you're taught to do right but in
America it's like when you you see like
a homeless person in America they're
like it's hard to describe they're very
much way more active and in your face
than compare compare it in comparison to
like other places in the world with like
homeless people I think it's harder
right you're harder to get by yeah yeah
they have a system that failed them yeah
yeah obviously one thing I think we all
noticed is that the homelessness in a
lot of the Cities was insane yeah
you know there's certain cities it was
like whoa California this is bad yeah
yeah I mean obviously because West Coast
it's a lot warmer all year round so a
lot of times people can live there yeah
um so that makes a lot of sense but man
you just you feel for them man you know
the system in America the way it's built
is not fair I I remember though uh Sarah
our VIP manager was just blown away by
the fact that it's like wait homeless
people don't just talk to you in Japan
it's like it's like what do they do and
I'm like you do you barely see them yeah
maybe in like Shibu or Shinjuku you
might see them but everywhere else dude
they're not there she's like where are
they all
and she just couldn't believe me when I
said like yeah homeless like I don't
have to deal with homeless people in
Japan yeah they just don't come up to
you and she just couldn't believe she's
like what what do you mean what do you
mean you don't have to deal with them
like as in they're not there and I'm
like yeah I mean I think in Japan
obviously talking about homelessness
there's a lot of um obviously how you
become homeless and the systems that
make you homeless in a sense yeah are
very I think impactful on then how as a
population maybe they behave or what
they need to do yeah Mary you've got to
be ruthless to get by oh yeah you know
in Japan I think there's there's more
options that you have and the the reason
why I think homelessness is hard to get
out of in Japan is it's so expensive to
get a place and if you don't have the
correct documentation it's impossible oh
yeah to get it sorted yeah and then a
lot of homeless people in Japan there I
mean there's some that you see sleeping
on the street but a lot of them how much
people in Japan live in manga cafes or
live in those hotels that are one night
and they're they're like 30 or something
really cheap oh they live like along the
river under them yeah yeah a lot of the
times they don't you know it's it's like
it's an entirely different system
because of the whole the whole way that
they become homeless and and the
barriers stopping them from getting out
of homelessness are different yeah and
so I you know it's very telling of the
system and what's in place yeah yeah
that's why in Japan it's different yeah
because I think it's just something that
if it's like your first time in America
uh because like my parents like came to
America for the first time this year as
well uh and it it shocked them because
they they'd never seen this kind of like
this you know this kind of like system
with uh with homeless people and you
know it's it's something that every
American knows how to deal with but if
you come outside from like come from the
outside to see what is the situation in
America it's just like very very like
shocking I remember the first time I
visited America and a homeless dude
talked to me I was like this is where I
die yeah I'm like I could see the
[ __ ] HP
oh my God I'm gonna have to fight my way
through the situation you know it's very
intimidating it is if you've never
experienced the US yeah especially if
you come from [ __ ] Japan you know
it's a scary [ __ ] I'm sure yeah it's
terrifying yeah it's depressing as well
because I hate seeing it online with
people like demonize homeless people and
they're like man that the [ __ ] worst
or it's their fault they're homeless
yeah maybe sometimes that is the case
but I feel like just labeling them as
lazy or whatever is is so not helpful to
the situation and uh it's so frustrating
yeah it's it's therefore if they're
homeless just buy a home yes right stop
buying Starbucks laughing that [ __ ]
drives me under the wall actually
actually yeah there was one situation I
think we were in uh Nashville uh
Tennessee there was a there was a
homeless dude that came up to me he was
a really nice guy yeah and just like I
actually had like a really nice
conversation with him and you know at
the end of it all like I I just gave him
like five bucks because I'm just like
you know what you're not actually all
that crazy I actually had a great
conversation with you you're respectable
about it whatever yeah that's fine so
yeah take my money but like you know if
you're gonna come up to me and be rude
and [ __ ] about it then like don't expect
change you know that's that's not how
you do this [ __ ] you know no I I I saw
one it was actually in Colorado actually
um you know there was there was a
homeless person uh who was asking for
money uh and you know a common response
was obviously sorry don't have any money
on me yeah uh you know I've only got a
card and he was [ __ ] prepared man he
he whips out this like one-on-one of
this you know the square [ __ ] yeah
it was like don't worry you can tip me
if you want I'm not like yo he's [ __ ]
hustling man yo yo marvelous dudes in
the 21st century holy [ __ ]
on his phone he's like I got PayPal I
was like no [ __ ] shocked me man I was
like holy [ __ ] I respect that I've
taught him many ways about it because I
I also like you mentioned like that one
with them was nice and some of them
aren't nice yeah well I don't know in a
weird way it's like man the government
should just [ __ ] help them why do I
have to decide which one is a good Court
Jester and which one amused me the most
yeah yeah give money out like a king
giving it to a peasant like I'm like
just [ __ ] help these people stop stop
doing wasting all this money on other
[ __ ] but I guess they say a lot of
people don't want to don't want to pay
yeah and also the problem's going on so
long now that there's no there's no
simple solution so ingrained and yeah
accept it it's just become a cycle now
unfortunately yeah yeah I mean currently
the system's broken and uh I'm not well
informed enough to unfortunately not to
fix it
that obviously America has a bad one but
like the UK and Europe is also not not
great at all oh Australia has tons of
homes yeah yeah for sure yeah I mean
house prices are [ __ ] insane yeah all
of Europe and Australia and America
right now and you know
it's hard to change the rules when the
dudes in top have uh have benefits yeah
in making sure the house prices stay
high yeah